Now we know how to find positions, sometimes called "indices," in strings.
What we want to do is chop up those strings into substrings.
Once I know where the spaces are, I can start splitting a sentence into words.
The Python syntax for this is to put square brackets after the string,
and the interpretation is "I want to get this substring that starts at this first number
and goes up to, but not including, this last number.
Here if I'm starting at 1 and going up to but not including 2, I'll get the "e" and the "l",
and that's exactly what we'd get in Python.
You can also leave out one of these numbers specifiers.
Leaving it blank means go as far as possible in that direction.
Here we're starting at position 1 and going all the way to the right so we get "ello."
Now that we know how to find strings and how to chomp them up,
let's combine that together and write a Python procedure.
Let's say that you're given two strings,
each of which itself contains two words separated by a space.
These strings might be "bell" space "hooks", "grace" space "hopper", or "alonzo" space "church".
I'd like you to write a Python procedure called myfirst_yoursecond that takes two arguments,
p and q, and returns true if the first word in p equals the second word in q.
For examples, myfirst_yoursecond of "bell hooks" and "curer bell" would return True,
because the first word here matches up with the second word there.
Submit it via the interpreter.